[Music]
dc
fans had to spend a long time waiting to
see the snyder cut of justice league
but this year the time finally came and
warner brothers released the film on hbo
max
the 4 hour long version not only has all
sorts of new scenes and villains it
also delves into the individual stories
of superheroes like cyborg
and flash who have not been in the
spotlight until then and introduces
brand new heroes to the mix
the four hours of superhero action not
only answer questions but also leave
some potential to
make more justice league movies how
likely is the sequel however who would
direct it and would all the heroes
return
we dealt with these and many more
questions in this video and we're going
to talk about them in more detail
in order to answer them we have to
mention some spoilers from the snyder
cut
so you've been warned summarizing the
whole movie from the start would
probably need a video of its own and
spoil the fun of watching it so today we
only deal with the most important things
for this video which are the ant
and the epilogue steppenwolf is killed
and darkseid fails to terror from the
earth as the mother boxes got separated
again
however he now knows that the anti-life
equation can be found on our beautiful
planet
and says that he's going to do it the
old way which in this case probably
means invasion
but what is the enter life equation
anyway it is an equation that can be
used to gain control over the minds of
all thinking creatures including
superman for example but it gets even
worse
you can also see how lex luthor escaped
from arkham and how he
now sends deathstroke after batman in
addition to that he reveals the true
identity of batman to the mercenary
most important though is batman's
nightmare in it batman is seen on a
post-apocalyptic earth
so the justice league seems to have
failed in their attempt to stop darkseid
he's not alone though as he's joined by
cyborg flash
mera deathstroke and the joker they seem
to be the last heroes who can still save
the earth
how they will do that doesn't appear to
be clear yet but they're definitely
dependent on the joker's help as he
himself points out while having a war of
words with bruce the last thing you hear
is a bang and cyborg saying
he's found us superman appears although
he doesn't seem to be the same
and just at that moment bruce wakes up
in his house by the lake they gets an
unexpected visit from the martian
manhunter who offers his help in the
fight against dark seed and the movie
ends
as you can see there's a lot of
potential in the ending of the snyder
cut
not only for more solo movies but also
for a continuation of zack snyder's
justice league story
so how probable are further parts so far
we have to admit that they're unlikely
in 2017 there were plans for additional
parts but in the course of time
they were scrapped the main reason for
this were the poor reviews for the first
film and the rather mediocre box office
takings
after justice league flopped in 2017
warner decided to completely abandon
films that converge in one storyline
as in the mcu there will still be some
solo movies which play in the same
universe but these are not to be based
on each other
now it depends on how the snyder cut is
received by the fans and above all on
its financial success whether those
responsible will change their minds
zack snyder has indeed already worked
out the further plot it was planned to
tell the entire story of the justice
league around the fight against darkseid
in three parts this being said
how could the plot continue as everyone
surely noticed at the end of justice
league duck said will finally make his
way
to earth to find the anti-life equation
he most likely suspects parts of this
equation to be
the subconscious of humans at least
that's how it's in the comics
not only will it be fought by the
earth's heroes but the green lanterns
will certainly play a role again as well
the justice league may expand since not
only would the martian manhunter now be
on the side of the heroes
also the superhero atom is into that his
civil name is ryan choi he is the
researcher who works with silas stone
in the end there will likely be a bitter
defeat for our heroes and the earth will
be transformed into the post-apocalyptic
planet which we briefly see in batman's
nightmare one question remains however
how does duck say succeeds in defeating
superman and controlling his mind
this one is easy to answer as the flash
has traveled back in time and is
actually
already given the answer those lane is
the key it would be conceivable the dark
side kill sir superman collapses and
this super villain gains control of the
man of steel
also not entirely far-fetched is the
idea that batman was tasked with
protecting her yet failed in doing so
that would fit if you recall joker's
line in which she says why you sent the
boy wonder to do a man's job without
superman the heroes are
unlikely to stand a chance against the
superior foe especially since they now
have to combat him as
well the earth will be nearly destroyed
and arguably most of the heroes will
lose their lives in battle
with only a handful of heroes still
alive part 3 of this series will
probably revolve around one topic
time travel how will the heroes manage
to go back in time to prevent low's
death
and superman's decline on the one hand
the answer is of course the flash since
he has already made a few time jumps in
the past but on the other hand
the joker also seems to play an
important role as he says himself batman
can't kill him because he needs him
what he knows that the others do not is
still unknown however it seems
conceivable that he got some information
from lex luthor who might have joined
darkseid
ultimately it will probably amount to
batman traveling back in time to
sacrifice himself so that luis can live
superman won't break down and the battle
if there was one would be one
similar to batman vs superman with a bed
you would have a martyr who sacrificed
himself for the earth
this is how the storyline of the two
parts could look like a few ideas have
been interpreted based on the scenes
we've already seen but other plot ideas
originate from snyder himself
as mentioned before the concepts have
actually already been put together
now fans just have to keep hoping that
the snyder cut becomes such a success
that warner will once again roll back
and turn the ideas
into reality another question that has
to be asked is whether all the actors
would still be available
particularly superman actor henry cavill
and batman ben affleck have found new
roles after the project was grabbed
cavalier in particular has a lot to do
with the filming of the witcher and if
the second season is as successful as
the first one
many more will surely follow things are
different for affleck who has reportedly
already given his ok for a comeback in
the upcoming flash movie if the cast
were to come together he certainly
wouldn't say no
cyborg actor ray fisher will surely be
more satisfied after the release of the
snyder cut ii
this is because his story and
development are the focus as it was
actually intended before however this
was cut out almost
entirely in the 2017 theatrical version
which the actor also found quite
upsetting in retrospect with
snyder however he would certainly work
together again since further solo films
are planned for wonder woman and aquaman
anyway they could of course continue to
be cast in justice league
the same goes for azramilah and the
character of the flash
therefore it doesn't seem to be a
mammoth task to get the crew together
again
not even caval could turn down the
opportunity if all his other castmates
were to persuade him to join them
before the video ends we have dealt with
a subject that will certainly also be of
interest to you
what is actually the anti-life equation
and how does it work
for this we ventured into the depth of
the internet and took a closer look
so that you won't have to do it its
first appearance is in jack kirby's
fourth world
it is an equation that empowers the one
who understands it to impose his will on
all sentient and gifted races throughout
the comics villains keep coming up with
the equation or at least parts of it
what it has often been defined in
different ways the consensus of all
definitions is that it is proof of the
futility of life
and the mini comic series seven soldiers
by grant morrison dark side is also
given the entire life equation and this
is where the equation has been
first written down it reads as follows
loneliness
plus alienation plus fear plus despair
plus self-worth
divided by mockery divided by
condemnation divided by misunderstanding
times guilt times shame times failure
times judgment
n equals y where y equals hope and n
equals folly
love equals lies life equals death self
equals dark side by uttering the
equation dark side can implant the
complete equation into the minds of
living
beings and thus control their minds
so that's it for all speculation about
the future of the justice league
we hope you enjoyed this video what do
you think will there be more parts
thanks to the success of the snyder cat
let us know in the comments we would
definitely love to see more movies
you